Mình đã mừng tầm thống xữa tổ mát, không chính thức về nằm của vỏ giúp hai bên kỳ đẹp bởi vì làm nằm kế lần của thịt quả giáu.
Chua chính đông đường của mình bánh giá, đây là sự kiện con chọt, có phần tạm đột phá,
đưa con hệ đối tác quan giết về nằm hú gery, nghe cảnh đý vào chêu sau kéo qua.
Cái nằm đường có chọt và hôm muốn tăng cơ hợp tác với hú gery,
đối tác ưu tiên hàng đầu, trong thời, đối tác quan giết đầu tiên của Việt Nam,
tại quên chung đồng hồ, chua chính đất chung đồng hồ,
thì về những thành tiệu phát triển kinh đe xa hội và hội nhập cho ông,
ngốc phần năng cao vị thế của hộn gery thải khu vận và triển thị dưới.
Bây giờ, hôm mình trong là đầu tiên đến thông Việt Nam,
trong thống xưa ốc tổ mát, tặc biệt ở tưởng tổ lần mà Việt Nam cạc được trong cơ cục của bởi,
hội dập của thế, nhưng mạnh của người rương có Việt Nam,
là đối tác quan chọng đất ở đúng nằm á và mông muốn tệ vạng tóc với Việt Nam,
trên tất cả các liên gần.
Chủ tình nông ngương cơm liều bật những thành tiệu mà Việt Nam đã được sau 4 năm đường mới,
giới sự đại đạo của đam.
Nên mạnh, cả rất tổng, đàn kết tổng thường kiện 2 buộc điều của chàng Nam.
Chủ tình nếu nhất chỉ với tổng thống xưa ốc tổ má,
cho rằng quanh hiện hai đúng, đã phát triển rất tình tổng,
kinh tế tổng là diện sáng, với chung ngày thứ 2 chiều,
đặt gần một tị đồ làm điên hồng ngoái.
Thật tóc về giá dụng, hàng tạo, khu chường, phần hóa, xu lịch,
của phần hành niên giá lưu dân, tất tổng, đặt kết quả,
tốt đặt.
Hãy bên cũng cho đổi về định hưởng những biển phát tục để quanh hiện
tăng cường tiếp xúc và cho đổi đàn khác tất,
tiếp là tức cao trên tất cả các cành,
thuộc để giá lưu dân giá nhằm tăng cường tì kể chi trịt,
và nhiều biết lẫn nhau, đăng li tàn,
kể mạnh tập tóc xúc phương trên mọi liên bật.
Hãy nhảy lệnh đạo khẩm điện,
thương mạnh, đầu tư là trụ cột quanh chọng cho quanh hệ xúc phương,
rất trí phát huyền hình nữa và cho quảy bán của nợp về hậu khá tình tế,
khuyến các mục ngành được phân và giống như hành lớp,
trị khai hậu phỏa hệ bệnh thương mạnh tục sau khi nằm  ew,
rất trí tăng cường tắc về công nghệ nụ tín,
hăng lợp, đúng nghiệp, công nghệp thương phần,
y tế, rực phòng, làm cầu đối giữa thì trường a sè n với rất sổ trên sảo trong
lắm với trường người, và sẽ đếp bê trên phố y tỉn đồ làm Mỹ với AIU,
trong đó có phút bật, chúng đông ở ổn,
trụ thể nếu nước cường cảm ơn gà rì là một trong những hư don tiền
phép tròn xếp địch khoảng hộ don tư tịnh thăm AIU,
tình nghĩ thúc để cắn rất AIU còn lại sớm phép tròn việc này,
cũng hộ ui bán trộ ổn, sớm cứ hợp bỏ thê phang,
đối với hài sản xuất thầu của Việt Nam.
Hãy bên cùng định xa sáng xúc cầu tạo tàu, là lịch vực hợp tác trường thống
trụ thể nếu cảm ơn gà rì, đã giúp Việt Nam đào tạo hình như gắn bộ,
trong đó có nhiều người dứt vị trí quá trọng trong bộ mấy nền nữa,
và nềm kịch tế Việt Nam.
Nhất chỉ xử dụng hiệu quả hai chăm só đọc bồng,
mà hôm gery cấp hàng năm cho xíc Việt Việt Nam
yêu tiên đào tạo trong những cuộc ít tế,
thông tin trường thông, môi trường.
Cảm ớt đúng gery luôn đánh ra cao cốc đồng người Việt Nam.
Chủ tiến nước để nghĩa hôm gery tiếp tục tạo thật lời,
trong cộng đồng, uống địa của sống,
huy nhất nghe cảnh sống dụng vào sửa tài.
Đóng có op cho sự phát triển của hôm gery cũng như quan hệ dựa hành ước.
Hành lệng đào cũng nhất chỉ với ở trong trẻ,
và hành hành hành hành hành hông.
Vì hợp tác và tị vận trung tòa,
trong đó có vấn đề Việt Nam,
tổng thống không có người tình ra hành ước có nhiều đẹp tương đồng
về chỉ xanh đứng ngoại và lệng sử dụng tòa.
Cùng ớt trường hà bình, cùng lý,
hài bình nất chỉ cho rằng các trình chấp và xung đột trên thế giới,
cündong dạc quyết phản biệt pháp hà bình,
trên cơ dở các vình tắc cơ bản của hí xâm liên được quốc và lột pháp phút tế.
Có phần vui chỉ hà bình, ông định,
anh đến tự gió hành hành và hành hông tại các khu vật và trên thế giới,
vì hợp tác và tị vận trung tòa cầu.
Chù chỉ chưa đại trọng thể tổng thống xước tòa mắt và đoàn.
Chù tình nếu rương cơ bột đình ước xanh trọng,
cảm ơn xử ủng hô, nước tởi báo và hư gà rì dành cho cái nâm,
trong khách dài đoạn lịch sử dụng.
Cùng gà rì và một trong người nước tổ phía nth giới,
đã cưng gặp và hư gà hư gà gà bình,
đảm ủy chà bình, thuy điểm mà phía nâm,
đàn gặp rất dự hoa khăn.
Chù tình nếu ngương cơm tý tuần trên nền tàn hữu gị trên hống,
được thử thách qua mình mới lạc nâm,
cùng tìm năng và trên phọc hợp tác tòa lớn,
bối có tâm của lệ gà, dần dần dần hành hước,
con hệ Việt Nam hung gà rì sẽ tích tổ phát trên mạnh mẽ,
tuy hoa bình, ổn định và phát trên bình bấm ở khu vật và trên thế giới.
Tổng thống xấu tổ má khẳng định,
sự hợp tác trả trẻ trong bà phần tư thế giới,
và đả trứng mình thay nước là đối tác trên thành tìm cạnh của nhau,
và trong bối cạnh tìm thế giới dịch bếp phút tạp,
những mỗi quan hệ hợp tác xong phương ủ định như giữa hung gà rì và phía nâm,
càng trở nên giả trị hình bà hợp hệ,
tổng thống cũng khẳng định,
những thành tí hoa phía năng đặc đột thư dân qua.
Có thể trở thành tấm hương cho nhiều cuối ra,
tí tưởng quan hệ giữa 2 sân tổng, sẽ tiếp tục phát triển và ngay càng rấn bó.